>>> LET'S BRING IN CNN POLITICAL
COMMENTATOR AND FORMER TRUMP
WHITE HOUSE COMMUNICATIONS
DIRECTOR ALYSSA FARAH GRIFFIN,
JOHN AVALON AND NORM IEISEN WIT
US AS WELL.
WHAT DO YOU THINK ABOUT NOW THAT
DOJ IS LOOKING SPECIFICALLY AND
ASKING QUESTIONS ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP'S CONDUCT?
>> I THINK IT'S A SIGNIFICANT
DEVELOPMENT AND I THINK MARC
SHORT, FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
PENCE'S CHIEF OF STAFF AND GREG
JACOB ACTUALLY SITTING DOWN WITH
THE GRAND JURY AND TESTIFYING IS
A HUGELY SIGNIFICANT STEP.
I'VE SAID THIS BEFORE, BUT MARC
SHORT IS BASICALLY PENCE'S EYES
AND EARS.
PENCE IS A STUDIED PRACTICED
POLITICIAN WHO DOES THINGS LIKE
HAVE THEIR CHIEF COUNSEL AND
CHIEF OF STAFF WITH THEM IN
VIRTUALLY ALL MEETINGS.
MARC SHORT HAD TREMENDOUS
VISIBILITY INTO EVERY STEP OF
THIS PRESSURE CAMPAIGN LEADING
UP TO JANUARY 6th AND WOULD BE
ABLE TO SPEAK TO THAT.
I THINK THAT -- AND THEN YOU
PAIR THAT WITH WHAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL SAID AND WE COULD BE
MOVING -- THIS IS THE MOST
CONFIDENT I'VE FELT AND I'M NOT
THE LAWYER AT THE TABLE -- THAT
WE ARE MOVING FORWARD A
POTENTIAL INDICTMENT OF THE
FORMER PRESIDENT.
>> AND WE WILL GET TO THE
LAWYER.
WHILE WE HAVE YOU, HAS THE DOJ
TALKED TO YOU?
>> THEY HAVE NOT SPOKEN TO ME.
I AM AWARE OF OTHER WHITE HOUSE
OFFICIALS WHO HAVE BEEN REACHED
OUT TO BY DOJ AND ARE PLANNING
TO COOPERATE.
>> OH, REALLY?
>> YES.
>> CAN YOU TELL ME MORE ABOUT
THAT BECAUSE THAT WAS MY
FOLLOW-UP QUESTIONS.
MARC SHORT, GREG JACOB, WE DON'T
KNOW A SINGLE OTHER PERSON.
>> I DON'T WANT TO GET AHEAD OF
THEIR ANNOUNCEMENTS BUT I THINK
YOU COULD PIECE IT TOGETHER
BASED ON WHO HAS TESTIFIED
BEFORE THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE.
AGAIN, THESE ARE NOT -- THESE
ARE RELATED BUT SEPARATE TRACK
INVESTIGATIONS AND I THINK DOJ
IS KEEPING AN EYE ON WHO IS
COMING BEFORE JANUARY 6th AND
WHO MAY HAVE HELPFUL
INFORMATION.
>> BUT YOU HAVE KNOWLEDGE THAT
DOJ IS REACHING OUT TO SOME OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE SEEN WHO
APPEARED AS PART OF THE JANUARY
6th COMMITTEE PRESENTATION?
>> YES, THAT'S MY UNDERSTANDING.
>> SO WHEN YOU HEAR DEMOCRATS
FRUSTRATED THAT DOJ HASN'T DONE
ENOUGH, HASN'T BEEN FAST ENOUGH,
DO YOU SHARE THAT CONCERN OR --
KNOWING WHAT YOU KNOW, DO YOU
THINK THAT ACTUALLY THEY'RE
FARTHER AHEAD?
>> I THINK THAT THEY'RE
PROBABLY -- I THINK THAT THEY'RE
MAYBE ON A BIT OF A DIFFERENT
TRACK.
I THINK THERE ARE PLACES THAT
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE WAS
PROBABLY MOVING FASTER AND HAD
MORE INFORMATION BUT I THINK
IT'S A BIT OF A MYTH THAT DOJ
ISN'T FAR ALONG IN THIS
INVESTIGATION AND ISN'T DOING A
WIDE REACHING AND METHODICAL
INVESTIGATION.
THAT SAID AS SOMEBODY WHO WORKED
IN THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND IS
EXTREMELY CAUTIOUS ABOUT DOJ
SEEMING PARTISAN, I THINK IT'S
INCREDIBLY CRITICAL THAT THEY
MOVE QUICKLY BEFORE THE FORMER
PRESIDENT IS AN ANNOUNCED
CANDIDATE.
JUST SEEING HOW THE POLITICAL
AND MEDIA TEA LEAVES ARE GOING
TO FALL, IF HE IS AN ANNOUNCED
CANDIDATE I THINK IT'S MUCH
HARDER TO PURSUE SOMETHING.
>> I DIDN'T MEAN --
>> SHE TOLD US --
>> HANG ON ONE SECOND.
I WANT TO GO BACK.
AGAIN, I DID NOT KNOW -- THAT'S
NEW TO ME -- THAT DOJ IS
REACHING OUT TO OTHER PEOPLE,
INCLUDING JANUARY 6th WITNESSES
SO THAT IS A BIT OF NEW NEWS.
IF WE CAN GO BACK, NORM, TO THE
NEWS THAT WE THOUGHT WE WERE
GOING TO BE TALKING ABOUT THIS
MORNING WHICH IS ASKING
QUESTIONS ABOUT DONALD TRUMP OF
THESE WITNESSES.
WHAT DOES THAT SIGNIFY IN TERMS
OF WHERE THIS INVESTIGATION IS
AND POTENTIAL JEOPARDY FOR TRUMP
AND OTHERS?
>> JOHN, I THINK IT SIGNIFIES A
DEEPENING JEOPARDY.
WE HAVE TALKED TOGETHER ON "NEW
DAY" FOR WELL OVER A YEAR NOW
ABOUT THE PROSPECT THAT DOJ WAS
GOING TO MOVE BECAUSE IF YOU
JUST LOOK AT WHAT'S PUBLIC
RECORD, THE OVERWHELMING
EVIDENCE OF MISCONDUCT BY THE
FORMER PRESIDENT AND THOSE
AROUND HIM, THE CLARITY OF THESE
LAWS, THE FINDING BY A FEDERAL
JUDGE IN CALIFORNIA THAT THERE
WERE LIKELY CRIMES GOING INTO
THE JANUARY 6th HEARINGS,
CONSPIRACY TO DEFRAUD THE UNITED
STATES AND OBSTRUCTION OF AN
OFFICIAL PROCEEDING IN CONGRESS.
GREG JACOB AND MARC SHORT
TESTIMONY FITS INTO THAT MOSAIC
PERFECTLY.
BY THEMSELVES IT WOULD BE HARDER
TO PLOT THE TRAJECTORY, BUT WHEN
YOU CONNECT ALL THE DOTS IT
REALLY POINTS TO LIABILITY.
THAT IS NOT A GUARANTEE OF
CHARGES OR CONVICTION.
AND YOU HAVE TO PUT IT TOGETHER
WITH SOMETHING ELSE WE'VE
DISCUSSED A LOT, THE GEORGIA
INVESTIGATION WHERE THERE IS AN
EVEN FASTER ACCELERATION.
SO YOU SEE A PINCER'S MOVEMENT
ON DONALD TRUMP AND PERHAPS THIS
WILL BE THE OCCASION IN WHICH HE
CANNOT DODGE CRIMINAL LIABILITY.
>> YEAH, LOOK, I MEAN, PEOPLE
OBVIOUSLY -- WE DO WANT TO PUMP
THE BRAKES BEFORE MAKING ANY
ASSUMPTIONS BUT PEOPLE POINT OUT
THAT AN INDICTMENT OF AN
EX-PRESIDENT IS UNPRECEDENTED,
SO IS WHAT HE IS CREDIBLY
ACCUSED OF WHICH IS INTERFERING,
TRYING TO OVERTURN AN ELECTION.
I THINK FOLKS WHO HAVE HAD AN
INTEREST IN THE OUTCOME OF AN
INDICTED PRESIDENT WHICH ISN'T
GOOD FOR THE COUNTRY I THINK
HAVE BEEN FRUSTRATED BUT HAVE
NOT APPRECIATED THE FACT THAT
THE DOJ CAN AND SHOULD BE
OPERATING AT ITS OWN PACE
BENEATH THE SURFACE OF THINGS.
THERE ARE FOLKS -- LET'S JUST
MAKE THE POINT, GOSH, IF TRUMP
DECLARES WILL THAT DERAIL THIS
INVESTIGATION?
WE HAVE SEEN THAT ATTEMPT TO
PLAY THE REFS BEFORE AND I THINK
THAT'S PRECISELY WHAT THE DOJ
CANNOT ALLOW.
THIS NEEDS TO BE WITHOUT FEAR OR
FAVOR AND THAT MEANS NOT HAVING
YOUR CALCULUS ADJUSTED BY
POLITICAL ANNOUNCEMENTS.
>> MERRICK GARLAND IS CLEAR HE'S
NOT GOING TO DO THAT.
DONALD TRUMP MIGHT MESS WITH
THAT A LITTLE BIT IF HE'S
LOOKING AT THESE HEADLINES
TODAY, THIS MIGHT CHANGE HIS
CALCULUS ON GETTING IN SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER.
>> IT MIGHT, MUCH TO I THINK THE
DISMAY OF REPUBLICANS WHO
DESPERATELY WANT HIM TO STAY OUT
OF THE RACE.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY.
>> KEVIN McCARTHY IN PARTICULAR
WHO SAYS -- HE HAS SPOKEN TO
DONALD TRUMP ABOUT THIS.
AGAIN, I THINK THE KEY POINT IS
WE'VE SEEN A LOT OF MISTAKES
MADE IN OUR -- WHEN PEOPLE
POLITICALLY GET IN THE HEADS OF
PEOPLE IN POSITIONS OF LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
THAT CAN'T HAPPEN.
>> THE FLIP SIDE, JOHN, ON
WHETHER IT'S GOOD OR BAD FOR THE
COUNTRY, I THINK IT IS GOOD FOR
THE COUNTRY AFTER THESE VERY
DIFFICULT TRUMP YEARS FOR THE
RULE OF LAW AND FOR NORMALCY IN
AMERICA TO HAVE ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> AND IT'S GOOD FOR THE WORLD.
THE WORLD IS WATCHING US.
IS THERE A PERSON IN THE UNITED
STATES WHO IS ABOVE THE LAW OR
IS EVERYONE SUBJECT TO IT?
>> I THINK THE IMPORTANT POINT
IS PEOPLE SHOULD NOT BE CHEERING
FROM THEIR RECEPTIVE PARTISAN
RAM PARTS ABOUT THE INDICTMENT
OF AN EX-PRESIDENT.
ACCOUNTABILITY IS KEY FOR
JUSTICE AND FOR HEALING AND
RECONCILIATION, BUT THAT IS A
SERIOUS MOMENT FOR THE COUNTRY.
>> IF WE CAN I WANT TO FOCUS ON
THE NEW REPORTING ABOUT WHO WAS
BEING ASKED AND WHAT THEY'RE
BEING ASKED ABOUT AND TRY TO
FIGURE OUT WHO ELSE THEY MIGHT
TALK TO.
NOW, ALYSSA, THIS IS A DIFFERENT
QUESTION.
IF YOU WANTED TO GET TO WHAT WAS
GOING ON IN DONALD TRUMP'S HEAD
AND POTENTIAL CRIMINALITY THERE,
YOU'VE TALKED TO MARC SHORT AND
GREG JACOB.
WHO ELSE MIGHT YOU TRY TO TALK
TO?
>> VERY CREATIVE WAY OF ASKING
THAT.
>> JUST GETTING STARTED.
>> PEOPLE SENIOR TO SHORT --
>> IT'S A WORTHY DISCUSSION.
I DON'T KNOW THAT YOU'RE GOING
TO GET MUCH SENIOR TO SHORT
UNLESS YOU'RE CALLING IN MARK
MEADOWS BUT I WOULD SAY THIS, I
THINK THAT A LOT OF WHAT I
PERCEIVE DOJ TO BE FOCUSING ON
IS THE PRESSURE CAMPAIGN AND THE
WEAPONIZING OF GOVERNMENT AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
HEADING UP TO JANUARY 6th.
OBVIOUSLY THERE IS THIS SEPARATE
TRACK OF, YOU KNOW, OBSTRUCTING
THE OFFICIAL PROCEEDING, THE
VIOLENCE AND ALL THAT, BUT I
THINK REALLY THINGS LIKE THE
FAKE ELECTORS, THIS PLOT TO SAY
THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT COULD
USE POWERS HE COULDN'T AND
COMMUNICATIONS THAT COULD HAVE
BEEN HAD AS PART OF THAT
PRESSURE CAMPAIGN.
SO I THINK YOU CAN GET A SENSE
OF WHO MIGHT HAVE KNOWLEDGE
AROUND THAT.
THE FORMER CHIEF OF STAFF IS
SOMEONE WHO IS IMPORTANT IN
THAT, PAT CIPOLLONE IS SOMEONE
WHO IS IMPORTANT IN THAT AND
THAT HE HAD VISIBILITY ON T BUT
AGAIN, WE HAVE HEARD FROM PEOPLE
SENIOR MID-LEVEL STAFFERS WHO
HAVE HAD INSIGHT INTO THIS.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WAS GETTING AT,
MEADOWS, CIPOLLONE.
NORM, CAN DOJ, WOULD DOJ TRY TO
GET THEM?
?
MEADOWS -- AGAIN, DOJ OPERATES
IN A DIFFERENT WAY THAN GEORGIA.
YOU ARE NOT GOING TO BRING
SOMEONE IN OR SUBPOENA THEM IF
THEY MIGHT BE A TARGET, RIGHT?
>> IT'S VERY UNUSUAL IN FEDERAL
PROSECUTIONS.
IT DOES HAPPEN.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE MANUAL
HAS PROVISIONS FOR HOW YOU GO
ABOUT IT IF SOMEONE IS A TARGET.
IT'S UNUSUAL.
I DOUBT THAT MEADOWS HAS BEEN
CALLED IN YET.
CIPOLLONE IS IN A COMPLETELY
DIFFERENT CATEGORY.
HE HAS KNOWLEDGE, HIS EXECUTIVE
PRIVILEGE CLAIMS, AS SOMEBODY
WHO HELPED ADMINISTER THOSE
CLAIMS IN A WHITE HOUSE, HIS
EXECUTIVE PRIVILEGE CLAIMS ARE
WEAK.
DOJ WON'T PUT UP WITH THE SAME
KIND OF BARGAINING THAT HE DID
WITH THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE.
JUST LOOKING AT THE ITINERARY OF
WITNESSES WHO WE HAVE SEEN
TESTIFY PUBLICLY, BILL BARR IS
GOING TO HAVE IMPORTANT
INFORMATION, HE IS A WILLING
PARTICIPANT.
WE'VE SEEN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN
INDIVIDUALS WHO APPEARED BEFORE
CONGRESS, THEY ARE LIKELY TO BE
BROUGHT IN.
AND ANYONE WHO CAN ESTABLISH
THAT DONALD TRUMP KNEW HE HAD
LOST THE ELECTION, HE KNEW THERE
WAS NO LEGAL BASIS FOR THESE
PHONEY ELECTORS AND YET HE
ATTACKED NONETHELESS,
CULMINATING IN THAT HORRIBLE
VIOLENCE AND CALLING OUT THE
VICE PRESIDENT.
THAT IS THE SINGLE MOST
UNFORGIVABLE THING TO ME, THE
2:24 TWEET.
SO THOSE WITNESSES ARE THE ONES
DOJ IS LIKELY CALLING IN